you wrote that many in the west believe
that the best hope for ending the
Ukraine war is to remove vladimer Putin
from power but you argue that uh this
isn't the
case can you explain well a lot of
people thought
when they were having all that trouble
the Russians were having all that
trouble with progan and the Vagner group
that Putin was was vulnerable and was
likely to be
overthrown and what would happen is uh a
peaceloving leader would replace Putin
uh I made two points at the time and I
would make those same two points now
number one he's not
likely to be overthrown he was not
likely then to be
overthrone uh and I think you know as
long as his health holds up up I think
he will remain in power my second point
is if he doesn't remain in power and
he's replaced I would bet a lot of money
that his replacement will be more
hawkish and more Hardline than Putin is
uh I actually think one could argue that
Putin was too trusting of the West
before the war
started uh and number two I think one
could argue that he has not waged the
war war against Ukraine as vigorously as
one might have
expected uh he was slow to mobilize the
nation for War uh and he has pursued a
limited war in all sorts of ways uh the
Israelis for example have killed more
civilians in Gaza in one month than the
Russians have killed over 18 months in
Ukraine
the idea that Vladimir Putin is waging a
punishment campaign and killing on
purpose large numbers of civilians is
simply not true uh all of this is to say
that uh I would imagine that if Putin
leaves office and someone else comes in
to replace him that someone else will be
at least if not more Hardline than him
in terms of waging the war and certainly
will not trust the West any more than he
has